[music]
It's 4:30 in the morning
on a remote mountaintop in the Chilean desert.
Pink Floyd blares through Ian Shelton's headphones
as he meticulously maneuvers a 10-inch telescope
at Las Campanas Observatory.
It's February 24, 1987,
and Shelton, a telescope operator,
is having a rough night.
The observatory's sliding roof door isn't working
when he arrives.
After finally getting it open, he spends three hours
painstakingly taking a picture of the
Large Magellanic Cloud,
a galaxy that orbits the Milky Way.
Suddenly a gust of wind slams the door closed,
[slam]
and everything goes black.
Shelton takes the hint.
Shelton: "Maybe I'll just call it a night."
But things are about to look up.
He takes the eight-by-ten photographic plate
to the darkroom and develops it.
Checking the exposure,
he immediately notices something odd.
Shelton: "There's this extra star that was
brighter effectively than all the other ones.
I figured why didn't I use that one
to line up the telescope?
Because it wasn't there.
It shouldn't be there."
Shelton checks it against the previous night's plate.
Nope, definitely not supposed to be there.
He grabs his jacket, steps outside and looks up.
Sure enough, there it is --
a bright point of light near the tarantula nebula.
Shelton: "For me, I was just quite surprised
to the point of a bit of disbelief."
So, Shelton heads down the road
to check with the guys at another telescope.
[door opening]
He casually asks fellow astronomer Barry Madore:
Shelton: "Well what would you say about a
a fifth magnitude object in the LMC?"
Madore does the math in his head.
Shelton: "And he says....ehh supernova
and then he looks at me, you know does a double take,
You're kidding!"
That's when telescope operator
Oscar Duhalde chimes in.
Shelton: "He says, 'Yes, yes, I saw something there, too.'
He was probably the first person to see naked eye.
Around 166,000 light-years away,
a hefty star had gone supernova.
It ran out of fuel,
and its core collapsed, starting a shock wave.
Ghostly particles called neutrinos helped push
the shock wave to the star's surface,
and it exploded.
The detonation spewed the star's
chemical gets into space.
Its end would churn up gaseous building blocks
for stellar construction.
Shelton and his colleagues were seeing this distant
light show 166,000 years later --
as close to real time as you could get.
The last time someone had directly observed
a supernova with the naked eye was in 1604.
So the crew at Las Campanas has to get the word out.
Except no one knows the protocol for
notifying the International Astronomical Union
about a supernova.
Shelton digs up an old article
in Sky and Telescope magazine.
Shelton: "A simple half page, quarter page little thing,
'How to report a discovery.'"
He tries calling the IAU office in Massachusetts.
[ringing]
Shelton: "It rang and rang. But it just never picked up."
So they go to plan B: Send a telegram.
They scribble a note and instructions on a piece of paper.
A driver sets off for the closest town, La Serena,
about a hundred kilometers away
in search of a telex machine,
the equivalent of email today.
For the astronomy community, it was a big, big news.
Shelton: "And I guess everybody thought
well now this is the big one."
Shelton's supernova became known as 1987A.
Its proximity to earth meant it could be
viewed with the naked eye
from the southern hemisphere -- a rare treat.
Stars go supernova all the time in the universe,
but 1987A confirmed a lot of things that
astronomers had theorized about the death of stars.
It also marked the first supernova where
astronomers could pinpoint
the identity of the progenitor star,
Sanduleak -69 202.
And it was the first time researchers detected
neutrinos from a stellar explosion.
It's been 30 years since Shelton captured
1987A's fiery blast.
Some scientists are still learning things from
the supernova and remains it left behind.
In the meantime, Shelton and others await
their next opportunity to see a star explode.
[music]